is there anyone who still drinks I don't
know I've instant coffee instant coffee
oh yeah I know I we just we're just
we're
rich we don't drink
what that was the most roundabout way of
saying right we don't weeg none of us
drink instant
coffee yeah we're not we're not uh can
we go back to instant
coffee I can't go I can't go it tastes
horrible yeah it's bad I mean it is
because like like I think at least
around where I live there is there is a
lot of like roasies like like local ones
that have really cheap beans that if you
just buy a really shitty grinder and you
wanted to do like a French press or
filter it yourself it's it's like as
cheap as getting the the giant that's
that's why I like asked just because it
seems like it seems like it's been
cheaper and cheaper to get like good
coffee you know even like even very
cheap coffee places have pretty decent
coffee at least in Europe you know at
least dude I bought I bought like a I
bought like a massive bag of coffee
beans the other day from Costco which
would probably set me back like if I
drink one cup a day or probably maybe
like a month and a half two months worth
it's like 1,500 Yen and it tastes really
[__] good I think people just care a
lot more about coffee now than they did
10 years ago and we also are like are
aware of how to make coffee taste better
the Tik toks first all the Tik Tok the
Tik Tok yes well okay it's it's the
ticktockers and the hipsters that have
like you know we we clown on hipsters a
lot but they've changed so much about
what has become readily available like
do you remember I don't know when this
started to happen but do you remember
when when did hipsters start start to
become the trend setters I mean they've
always been that's the point they've
always been the trend setters and when
then we've clowned on them and then
we're like wait a minute actually this
thing did you see that um talking about
hips did you see that one Tik Tok of
that guy who's an LA guy in California
no in New York he's like so like what's
the deal with new Yorkers man like I I
went to you know in California in La if
I asked for a scooped Bagel gluten-free
there's no problem they're like yeah
thank you I asked for in New York and he
said I'm not [__] doing
that in New York I just walked in and
asked for a sto gluten-free Bagel guy
just looks at me he goes I'm not
scooping your [__] bagel bro he's
like dude that's how I want it he's like
get the [__] out of here with that [__]
okay all right have you heard what A
scooped Bagel is no oh my God this
pissed me off what the [__] is a scooped
Bagel is where you get the bagel and you
scoop out the bread so what you just
left with the outside of it the shell
why exactly why what do you fill in that
scoop part because obviously the bagel
you'd normally put like you'd kind of
you know squeeze it like yeah like like
of bre the idea is that you can remove
some of the carbs and calories and still
get like the sensation of eating a a
bagel how about you just not eat a bagel
yeah and I think a lot of the internet
reacted very viscerally and were like
what the [__] how I I would kick you out
people were like you're lucky you didn't
get killed in New York
C bang it is an insult to Brett I feel
like you shouldn't be committ don't be
committed to the bread train if you're
going to ask them to throw away half of
it I just I like what do they do with
that bread presumably throw it away or
maybe maybe compost it or give it to
someone or feed it to animal I don't
know something Bakers all over the world
are [__] frothing at the mouth right
now I feel like it's just a hate crime
yeah against bread makers yeah that's so
rude just if you don't want to eat
stop [__] eating throwing away the
crust on a
pizza I mean I mean not looking at
anyone in particular I mean I don't I
don't have a horse in this race Pizza
scooped can I get my pizza scooped
please can I get my P imagine going to
like a a bagel place and being like hey
remove all of the hard work yeah F go
[__] yourself remove the thing that's in
the name of your store but the guy like
seemed I think it was the the guy seemed
so upset that the guy was very angry
that you didn't want to do this and I
think that's what kind of made people
like you're not entitled to this man to
ruin his bread yeah um I mean like I'm
trying to think what other Trends have
like popped up recently that wasn't
there when when I was like there growing
up like I remember everything yeah
anything on Tik Tok I thought like craft
beer was a fad at first craft beer
didn't exist when when I was it just
didn't exist and then like I remember I
think it was very hard to brew beer at
home but obviously the technology has
gotten so much better to brew it at home
than obviously canning you think the
coffee Mak for
that yeah yeah I mean yeah you can you
know you can also like can beer now that
is something that is accessible and you
can do that on a very small scale
whereas canning canning stuff before was
like a very very expensive thing and you
did these giant machines to do and and
so that's why like still in a lot of
places they when you do like craft beer
it's um what is it [__] it's um either
Cask or it's in bottles normally
actually no bottling is very expens as
well what am I saying there's a
different way you would score it I know
can basically yeah I'm going off on one
there yeah yeah cuz like I'm I'm trying
to think about what is like it is
basically the hipsters have started a
lot of these trends that you know get
passion about something I certainly
thought craia was a fad when it so first
started popping up and then I don't know
if something just changed in my brain to
be like actually tastes pretty good just
have a [__] Budweiser or with
everything people just get bored of
having the same goddamn beer cuz like
beer drinkers you know know for a long
time it was kind of like you had like
three options yeah whenever you went to
your local place so it's kind of nice
having like a rotating selection of
stuff but also sad when you get a really
nice craft beer and then it's gone I'm
like yeah yeah it's always just like
takes time right and it's like EV like
who knows 3 years from now I might come
up to someone and being like wait you
get your bagels UNS scooped the [__] is
wrong with you you know what was uh so I
went to twitchcon uh last week and um in
Vegas I nowhere does draft beer it's all
bottled and I was yeah I it was like
barely anywhere I I i' I think there's
only one place I could find it that had
draft beer but nowhere else had draft
beer and I just I like beer a lot so I'm
always like hey what do you have on what
do you have on tap cuz I'd much rather
have something that I maybe wouldn't
drink from a draft than something from a
bottle that I would drink cuz I'm like I
just want to it normally tastes way
better but nowhere had it it's called a
faucet
actually yeah Americans just don't that
beer game is Just so bad yeah the beer
game is awful what did you drink what I
drink I normally just would get bottled
beer like like rebottled beer no bottled
beer they pour it out of the cake and
then they just it's not a California
thing yeah can you scoop the scoop the
beer out please can I get my beer
scooped can you shake the carbonation
out please I like my beer uncarbonated I
mean a lot of the drink drinks are bad
so I was like I'll just take a bottled
beer of I don't know an IP or Goose
Island or something they had that
everywhere so I had that oh Goose Island
that's yeah it's okay better than a
Budweiser what do you guys think of uh
lacroy or Tela water I like it I uh
hated it at first and then the hipsters
got me [__] knew it same thing with
um like when I told you guys I was like
guys you should try this whiteclaw thing
if you want to drink out same thing with
whiteclaw I was like what the hell is
this [__] I don't want to drink it end
of our La trip I was obsessed well it's
cuz you can just kind of you can go to a
party and like if you if you have to
drink or you feel obliged to drink which
you know obvious shouldn't have to you
want to the progression for me was crazy
with whiteclaw like it started with like
what the [__] is this like C alcohol
cell this is [__] now I'm at that
point where I go to a friend's party and
I'm just I judge them on what flavors
they have it's definitely going to take
off and so you only have the lemon the
[__] is wrong with you it's going to
catch on here I'm surprised there hasn't
already caught on here there's so many
low calorie alcohol options here you
need to get in on that train
I'm sad that he hasn't caught on in the
UK yet the UK is still in that phase of
like clowning on white claw cuz you
can't even get it at like every
Supermarket it's only at like some
select supermarkets and every time I've
been caught drinking a white clor in the
UK I get beat
up everyone's like changed wow wow guess
because we have such good cider and such
good beer and it's like man I why why
would you want to drink that but I I get
it it's perfect for a country like here
though like 100% cuz Jaan would love it
yeah
so many sparkling water DRS they already
have like hottoo and stuff like that
right like we're almost there hottoo is
just that's just juice that's just juice
with a tiny bit of alcohol at it just to
make you feel Hasbro is my first alcohol
well it's called horo right which is
like buzz not even Buzz it's like I feel
a bit warm yeah yeah right it's like
yeah okay my body temperature went up